if you use your credit cards you do not
want to be rich anytime you say
something about that people send it to
me
look at what Cubans vice versa yeah so
cut up your credit cards if you use a
credit card you don't want to be rich
yep I like that line that's a good one
that's my favorite line I tell people
all the time people then they ask me
well where's the best place to invest I
said your best place to invest is to pay
off all your credit cards and burn them
because your credit card you know what
your return is right if you get off you
know you're paying 15 20 interest if you
pay that down you just earn 15 or 20
percent folks I've told you 100 times
and uh Forbes 400 400 wealthiest people
in North America when surveyed ask
what's the way to build wealth what's
the number one way to build wealth 75
percent of wealthy people not your broke
brother-in-law with an opinion but
wealthy people say get out of debt and
stay out of debt yep because it gives
you power over your largest wealth
building tool which is your income